on the show today Legends of Tomorrow
get ready for Fatman on Batman Punchy
Punchy smashy
[Music]
smashy welcome hello and welcome to
Fatman on Batman I'm Kevin Smith Mark
Bernard uh today's show folks if you're
not into uh Legends of tomorrow on the
CW verse the cwdc verse it's a lot of
letters the berente verse there you go
although I'm sure CW takes exception to
that they're like what about the CW
verse um DC Universe on TV is on CW we
know this uh because of course it began
with well I mean look give props they've
were doing this [__] since [__]
Smallville right wasn't that a c WB show
it totally was and a c w show that went
on for 98 years it was forever man that
shows they even did Bizarro and [__] and
then like uh they did Arrow yep berlan
kicks open the doors with arrow which
took off and gave birth to one of my
[__] favorite shows the flash yeah um
The Flash and arrow and Greg bante and
[__] Andrew churg and and Jeff Johns
all these cats who work on your favorite
uh flaro shows over at CW have come up
with a new one and you can't miss it
it's [__] being advertised everywhere
everywhere they're doing a great job
marketing it and not in like oh my God I
can't I'm sick of seeing it already
they're doing a great job it looks like
a [__] feature like they're marketing
it like it's a movie man and that's like
that's a great [__] time to be alive
I know I say this every week it's a
great time look it's always a great time
to be alive even except when you're
being tortured to death I would imagine
that Abu gra is probably not a great
place to be alive we didn't mean to
bring it down but right off the top yeah
right people are like now you got be
thinking about prisoners of conscience
[__] pointing to genitals things could
be a lot worse kids but it's a great
time right now man because they're
taking things that we love giving it
serious treatment putting serious
[__] money into this [__] let's talk
about this Legends of Tomorrow DC's
Legends of tomorrow yes they're not
[__] around anymore they Brandon
[__] like finally they don't call it
DC's Arrow or DC's flash but now they're
calling it DC's Legends of tomorrow man
like forget it everyone everything's
Marvel Marvel Marvel we got a brand just
as big don't hide it man don't [__]
be ashamed of it like don't be
embarrassed be what you are and now
we're seeing what it is man it's the
show is going to be [__] massive we
watched it so we're going to talk about
it this episode but before we dive into
it just a bit of news um from your
corner of the world it is I you know on
this show I don't like to toot my own
horn I like to cover other things and
whatnot but sometimes Mark it's worth
toting or these things cross over
sometimes you can't help it we talk
about Flash a lot on this show so much
so that on the audio version we had
Andrew churg as a guest who was amazing
fantastic Tarter if you haven't listened
to go listen to it um we put up on this
very Channel me balling at the season
finale of flash season one as you do
everybody does um it's the new Field of
Dreams every
man every man cries watching it so um
they announced at the what is it TCA the
television critics Association which is
tell them what that is for those that
don't know it is twice a year every
Network every TV producer gathers
together and presents their Wares to all
of the journalists who write about TV
for a living so they do one in the
winter and they do one in the summer the
winter showing off mid-season shows
summer shows off the fall shows and it's
basically they all just parade
everything that they've got and drop
whatever news they have and it's a big
sort of shows shows beautiful shows like
strolling them out like an old [__]
Beauty B yeah and so this is the time
where they started announcing which
Pilots they're going to shoot and they
start making those announcements and
which shows and hey look let's tomorrow
here's the pilot here's the whatever and
here's a thing that we think you would
like to know about dear readers and so
everybody said they bring the whole cast
in or creators or junk yeah or they will
bring the journalist to the set and hey
you want to tour catco sure I will
happily sit in cat Grant's chair and
take pictures of myself and they do that
kind of thing they do that kind of thing
well during the TCA they announced
something that I've known for quite a
while I've been sitting on and not
saying anything he knew it too so he
didn't say anything so [__] good on
you yeah I tried um I'm going to direct
a flash episode [__] bananas look at
that that's a that's an artist rendering
of what it's going to look like yeah me
wearing a flash shirt balling run Barry
run this is awesome um I can't thank the
folks over there enough man like uh
Andrew churg obviously the man who made
it happen you want some people like
how'd this [__] happen do you want to
know how it happened and this is how
like [__] startlingly easy it is and
[__] sometimes you just need somebody
thinking for you in a way that you don't
think for yourself I like I would never
be like dude let me on that show because
that just sounds SS grabby and [__]
and also like why weird you know what
I'm saying like just cuz you love a
thing doesn't mean that you got to be
involved with the thing you know but
because I work in
entertainment often times there's a
chance to love a thing and be involved
with a thing as well so you know I I I
never want to be the guy that's like
givee give me give me so I would never
[__] think to ask even that [__]
like well Andrew came over after I
already got the gig but even if he was
there I would never have like hey man
[__] like it just I think that's when
[__] gets weird that would be like
trying to you know kiss a girl who is a
friend yes did that once in high school
[__] awkward really awkward just and
she was just like so the source of
unrequited love basically oh okay with
your tongue hanging
out maybe that's why I didn't get kissed
I don't know maybe
the they're like oh my God he's having a
stroke a blind man looking for fruit
I believe that's a yoga move blind man
looking for fruit in any
event um this the hero of this story
Mark is not flash really the hero of
this story is Jason Muse's wife Jordan
huh Jordan runs our company smco and
Jordan like saw me [__] crying up a
storm and talking about Flash and
[__] talked about Flash over and over
on a bunch of different podcasts and she
called up my agent and was like he seems
to like the flash will you call them and
see if they'll let him direct an episode
of The Flash and if i' known she was had
done that I'd be like no cuz that's so
against my [__] character and [__] I
don't ask for things I just go do my own
thing but she [__] asked boy Jordan
girl Jordan who runs our company asked
boy Jordan who's my agent to go ask
flash people and he called up Andrew
churg and Andrew chur this is how it
happened he goes oh yes and that's it
like I could have done this [__] years
ago you know what I'm saying never
thought of it but if it was ever to
happen happening on this is on flash is
an amazing thing now I've seen like a
lot lot of support for it on the
internet crazy man normally a lot of
people are like [__] you you fat piece
of [__] and everything you do but even
people who are like [__] you normally
are like don't [__] this up Mitchell you
know like 3 fck High don't [__] this up
Mitchell but there seems to be a lot of
like oh this might be a good blend he
likes this [__] and he's known to direct
and it's not a feature so he's not gonna
get himself hurt too badly let's have
him do that but I'll tell you right now
this [__] that bar is high [__]
those flash shows are better than most
[__] movies I watch saw someone
online go [__] like this never works
when you bring somebody else's [__]
sensibility into an already established
sensibility nothing good could come of
it and [__] I'm here to tell you that's
that person's not [__] wrong I am not
going into flash going like how many
dick jokes can I stuff in this
[__] like I love flash like I
don't want to go in and make mine I want
to go in and make theirs man I play in
their sandbox and [__] I got my whole
world to [__] do whatever I want have
mooses eating people and [__]
walruses that [__] little Nazi sausages
that's all of my movies in one Mash Up
movie in a convenience store um at them
all but I mean I could do that in my
world and [__] when I go to flash World
dude I'm playing in the court like I you
know this is
like I just want I'm going to pull this
analogy just because I watched this
documentary recently so we know metal
Ark lemon died a couple weeks ago yes
metalark lemon gigantic name of my
childhood absolutely in a CH in a world
where we had three channels like metal
Arc lemon was as famous as George
Washington or George Jefferson for that
matter like they there were people that
got on TV that were [__] famous and
there were only three channels so that
pool Super Famous like more famous than
anyone will ever be from now until the
end of time even with social media and
[__] because those were in the days were
like hundreds of million of people
watched television and [__] like that
and only had three channels to watch
Harlem Globe Charters man had it all
like [__] oh my God just like Tim
Miller they had the world B of balls
that kid who directed Deadpool who was
like 50 they they had everything man and
this isn't Behind the Music where it's
like and then they lost it they had it
all man it's [__] they had cartoons
movies they were always on TV and
[__] gillig they got off Gilligan
Island the only [__] get off
Gilligan Island were the Harlem Globe Js
a game to play um plus they were just
brilliant like clown princes of the
basketball court but what most people
don't realize is like they began their
lives like all of those people on the
har Globe CHS are expert Ballers yes
more so as good if not better than NBA
Ballers um and back in the day in the
early fledgling days of the National
Basketball Association they had a game
with the Harlem Globe Charters I think
it was I the Lakers it might have or it
could have been even like the ABA before
they merged no it was it was a team that
I recognized I was like oh my God it's
them and they play it wasn't like the
Knicks I want to say it was the Lakers I
don't know 76ers maybe maybe they play
them and kick their [__] ass and [__]
like that and those cats are known as
like you know [__] all they spin
basketballs and [__] on their finger but
they came to play yeah they played their
the game as it's supposed to be played
they weren't jumping up people's [__]
necks and you know [__] Duncan with
three people and [__] wearing a costume
balls up the shirt no where to go they
played [__] completely straight and
they won the game and stuff that's how
I'm heading into this I'm playing it
straight I'm not going in there and
trying to bend the rules and do it my
way and [__] like I want to do it their
way I like otherwise I wouldn't go you
know what I'm saying I don't want to be
the guy that [__] up the show that I
like I already did that on Cinema Sins I
will never do that again [__] I
will never be told by the audience you
ruined the thing that you love and be
like I did didn't I F oh [__] never
so I'm going to go up to flash and like
[__] kick as much ass as possible um
a because well I don't want to embarrass
myself but B I'm a fan of the [__]
show like and I want to continue
watching the show and I want people to
continue watching the show I don't want
there to be like this oh that was the
one Bad episode so you watch man there
ain't going to be no dick jokes in it
and [__] uh you know I'm not going to
say there's no references whatsoever and
stuff because I ain't writing the script
that's the other thing people are like
put in this put in this I ain't doing
dick like I'm honoring those [__]
scripts they hand me man I never watch
The Flash and Go I would have written
that different or I would have written
that better I watch The Flash and I
[__] ball when the credits roll I'm
like why can't I ever be this [__]
good I'm not going to [__] put my
[__] in their script man I'm [__]
taking their script I'm going to try to
translate it I'm going to try to elevate
it not execute it as best I can but I
look forward to it man big thanks to all
those cats who were like come on up and
play it's really nice super [__]
sweet man but all goes back to Jordan
like yeah can you imagine more useful
Jason Muse's wife is more useful than
Jason Muse Jason Muse never once thought
to call up Greg brante and be like hey
man oh can you let moves direct and it
would have benefited him cuz I could
have put him in it but no now I'm
putting Jordan in it oh nice yes so
anyway I get to direct a flash man that
is so [__] great right now it is you
know it's like if I [__] it up then like
six months from now I'll be like
remember when I did the flash and'll be
a joke for a while I ain't letting that
happen man not with this I like this
[__] too much so I believe I go up in
March that's awesome yeah so we'll be
[__] filing reports from the set and
stuff I'll be like look at this [__]
interview a bunch of mother oh you ain't
kidding um all right so there's that
that's going on which is awesome very
sweet now back to Legends of tomorrow
which we saw we totally did this show
rocks man um I wrote down a bunch of
[__] notes but why don't you start
with your thoughts because I'm always
blabbing I give him a single for Christ
sakes I didn't write down any
notes go back to the two
shop well kids as you can see Mark's
prepared and we're just talk
extemporaneous I mean it's it's the
thing I love about this show and I'll
tell you there's a couple things I love
about this show okay um but you could
tell from the very beginning and when we
talked to Andrew churg he said his
favorite show in the whole world is
Doctor Who yeah and this is very much
like I got myself a companion from
Doctor Who to be my doctor who who leads
a bunch of guys through time so it's
like Doctor Who meets Quantum Leap it's
like Dr DC who Dr DC who there he is Rip
[__] played by Arthur darville
who's amazing um the uh he's old school
DC character I remember him first place
I carum he goes back to the the Silver
age or some [__] maybe even golden age
but uh Jeff lobe who runs Marvel TV and
stuff he uh he was one of the first like
non-comic book people to go work in
comics that I ever saw he did uh um a
couple issues of course well he did many
things eventually but his first thing
was a challenges of the unknown Min
series Tim s and rip Hunter was in that
that was my first introduction to him
love this character love the idea that
they're like let's [__] use him man
and he's a superhero doesn't dress like
a superhero so costume wise he laser
sick shooter and a badass [__] time
ship oh my God it is uh it is a it's a
group show yeah it's a team show really
is Doctor Who a team show um would you
consider that I mean it's it's his it's
usually like it's a two-hander for the
most time it's it's the doctor and
whoever's companion is it happened to be
on the year that Arthur darville was on
Amelia Pond um played by Karen y gu was
close there getting
geek who was nebula and Guardians of the
Galaxy oh really yeah she shaved her
head and everything the [__] man look at
the Deep Cuts we're getting from Mar cut
but yeah so she was the companion and he
was her fiance who eventually got
married so it became a three-hander and
it became really sweet and she went on
to Marvel and he went on to DC yes I
wonder if they talk at conventions now
tearing them apart no they're not
allowed to DC and Marvel people aren't
allowed to talk the Sharks and the Jets
do they have dance fights they do
um you're a Marvel you're Marvel the
best Grant Gustin cuz he was on [__]
Glee before he was the flash he was
[__] belting it out he's a hoofer and
a singer a hoofer he is literally a
hoofer man on that show he's like I get
to direct that kid it's so great and
direct I ain't going to tell him what to
do I'm just going to be like [__] do
that thing where you made me cry run
there's a lot of [__] why is Kevin's
only Direction run Barry run they're
like Kevin can't direct he's too busy
balling I'm just like oh God it's so
beautiful
you're just super lady she's like I'm a
[__] dude run Barry run my name is
Cisco on the show run Barry
run why can't you run like Barry run I'm
not the fast one I it's all going to go
south isn't it this is going to work
can't you can't [__] have a fan
direct this [__] like I literally won't
be able to do anything the whole time
I'll be like do that thing I love
they're like should we
roll they're there
it's the flash people I'm just going to
walk out I'm just going to touch it over
here is that cool I'm going to get geeky
it's going to be great yeah I won't be
able to control myself or my bladder um
let's talk about this show though
Legends of tell me what you love here's
what I love about this show give me a
single give me a single there you go
here's what I love about the
show they s this is the Justice League
movie before the Justice League movie
this is Avengers on TV this is guardan
the Galaxy to some degree on TV this
this looks like a feature it's big big
Ideas you know what it also looks like
this is a bullia Baye of everything
you've liked about comic book movies for
the last 10 years there's a little bit
of [__] X-Men Days of Future Past
mixed in cuz they're wearing going to
time periods and [__] wearing the
clothes and [__] like that little bit
grooviness there there's a bit of Doctor
Who there's a bit of Justice League
which hasn't come out yet but there's a
bit of Avengers bit of Guardians of the
Galaxy and I I think it's great and of
course a lot of [__] big Heap and
dose of [__] Flash and some Arrow I
guess but um my God this [__] stew is
tasty [__] like that's what I'm saying
is you're not going to tune in and be
like I'm as baffled as I was when I
watched Rubicon on AMC all those years
ago not at all this very easy to follow
just the way that flash is a comic book
come to life Legends tomorrow Absol is
is like a comic book movie come to life
which is weird to say on the small
screen um seriously in a in a fair world
this [__] would be in in the movies but
it benefits all us that it's not a fair
world because we get to watch it weekly
on television you know is for Nothing
free for nothing [__] as opposed to
like shelling out [__] 10 15 bucks
with a year two years between each
episode you can sit here and watch this
every week and they killed it on this
show man I don't know they who directed
he told us the guy the pilot Whisperer
directed I think [__] I can't remember
he directed their AR their Flash pilot
as well yeah [__] did a killer job
man but here's what I love about the
show you've seen the commercial spot you
know where they're all up on the rooftop
and rip Hunter's like you know oh no in
the future because basically rip Hunter
comes from the future and collects a
team of Heroes to stop Vandal Savage
from destroying the world who [__]
everything up in the year 2222 or
whatever the hell it is so they're like
we got to go [__] time and they're
going to stop him from doing that [__]
so in that trailer the sizzle reel they
shot for the for the show you know rip
Hunters talking to everyone on the roof
and and uh you know he's they're he's
they're going so wait in the future
we're heroes he goes no no you're not
just Heroes you're Legends so you
realize take these Rag taggers and
you're like oh my God they're the
[__] Justice League and I was sitting
there going how smart they don't have
Batman Superman but they're like we
don't need those [__] and they built
a goddamn [__] Justice League out of
it and on the surface the premise is
that it's simple beautiful we collect
these Heroes go back in time and [__]
stop this bat man you're like right on I
[__] like this but then about Midway
through the show MH they [__] hit you
with the feels of what the real story is
and it's not like an M Night shamalan
[__] twist it's just you didn't know
the whole story and the whole story is
even more moving there's a scene with uh
you know who to me who I [__] love in
the show is Brandon Brandon Ru so good
[__] so good man like he's he's I I
worked with him M Zach Mir mcor he's
[__] brilliant he's wonderful kid but
he's so good as [__] Ray Palmer
because he's so like anxious happy to be
involved knows that he's [__] smart
and they use him so well in this because
he's this emotional Touchstone yeah he's
got the great suit and he shrinks so he
does the cool [__] but he doesn't do
that very often in it you know most
expensive that [__] is expensive so most
of the time it's he's left to his own
acting chops and stuff and they give him
some great [__] to work with first when
rip hter gives them the the hey thech
this is the pitch you got a day to think
about it he's talking about it and he's
thinking about who he's talking about
with well I forget who it I don't know
if it's Martin Stein or whatnot but he's
like I died once and you know what
happened nobody cared nobody noticed
life went on like this man is telling me
that in the future my life makes a
difference so he's like I think I have
to do this really touching reason CU you
know I guess it was an arrow he shrank
and and they thought he died but he just
[__] went small so you know you're
like that's [__] that's cool man like
and that that hit me I was like Jesus
Christ like I immediately that's when I
started crying I wish I had a camera on
me cuz on that cuz all the best tears
are on camera but right when he said
that I was like that's the [__] feels
that's how they got me go to Mark yeah
no they totally got
him I I mean I love the pace of that
that especially the first episode it is
[__] breathless it just it's like
Oceans 11 where we're building a gang of
superheroes and a couple of villains and
I love the villains you know those two
good move including them yeah because it
it it builds conflict into the team
because all these shows are about you
know it's Heroes fighting a thing and TV
is about drama and drama is about
conflict and it really smart by building
that conflict in so if they never go
anywhere if they never run into a bad
guy externally there's conflict on the
[__] [__] can you go to a shot this
is why you bring a mark Bernard anywhere
man he [__] sees into [__] and he
understands what makes it work he's like
a [__] clock maker you know what I'm
saying he knows how it all puts together
and [__] like that I never would have
thought of that you're absolutely right
even the conflict thing about TV [__]
yeah because like at some point they're
going to run out of
money because every once again wisdom
from Mark Bernard they used to call him
bottle shows yeah where it's like it's
all on standing sets we're never leaving
Star Trek was awesome at this cuz you
know hey so there another ship on the
screen which we're only going to show
once we're never beaming down to a
planet we're never fighting any other
aliens it's all here because this
doesn't cost us anything was it called
bottle shows was in a bottle um that was
the ultimate bottle show I don't
entirely know where the the entomology
comes from but um but yeah so like you
can absolutely just do a show on that
time Master ship whatever the name of it
is like exelor it's not called that oh
it's got the what the Wave Rider The
Wave Rider The Wave Rider you know like
they can do a [__] an episode where they
never leave that ship and there will
absolutely be reasons for the hateful a
on the Wave
Rider the hateful yeah there it is how
many people one two three four I like
that I do like how this the ship is set
up for uhum style so we can see our
whole cast nobody's blocked like that
everybody wins no [__] ship needs to
be set up like this but nope it's
beautiful I loved it when they walked in
they're like everyone get a seat I'm
like how perfect yeah you knew there
would be n us okay great oh I love
fiction um but it's really smart that
way it's really really smart that way
super smart I'll tell you the other
thing it's got going for it man the real
[__] plug of the show spoilers big
spoilers yeah this is all [__]
spoilers so we talked about Ray decides
to go cuz he's like I could make a
difference I don't want to be forgotten
and stuff Midway through the [__]
first one or second one what did they
first one first one they don't [__]
yeah I was happy like right away I was
like Jesus Christ like you could have
hid this till episode
for sure right in they don't bury the
lead it's right in the pilot rip Hunter
reveal spoilers go to two shot huge
spoilers spoilers the size don't watch
this until you watch that throttle back
that we mean Legends of tomorrow just
we're all [__] clear go back to the
single all right the other guy yeah [__]
it no me do me um so rip Hunter reveals
that he is wanted by by what it's the
time counsil like his version of the
time Lords or whatever um The Time
Masters um wanted because he jumped into
the time stream to go kill R Vandal
Savage without blessings from his
Masters and stuff so they send
Kronos time Bounty Hunter to [__] go
kill him Kronos is a ray Palmer Adam
villain so right right away you're like
oh I [__] love this I love how
[__] geeky this is so rip Hunter was
not sent from the future rip Hunter took
a ship and came from the future yes so
at a certain point they they have them
he freelancing they have the big
conversation about like well if that's
not what really happened if we're if you
weren't sent to get us what happens to
us in the future and that's where the
show owned me right the right here man
like I I was digging in I was like I'm
in but like I expected high adventure I
did not expect the [__] heart moment
man and again don't you don't want it
spoiled for you if you haven't seen this
don't watch if you haven't seen it
but rip Hunter tells them he's like you
got none of you matter to the time
stream like I chose you because all of
your deaths have no effect on the time
stream whatsoever nobody gives a [__]
about them I'm like I get I'm getting
[__] sad about it right now I'm like
that is so [__] heartbreaking they're
all heroes they'll put themselves and
their lives in danger for others and
[__] and this man comes to the Future
he's like Batman yeah Superman Wonder
Woman Adam not so much you nine [__]
nobody a [__] so sad dude that's I don't
know I mean I don't feel like a winner
most days so that's what I feel like
that guy so I watched that and I was
like like they're all the kids who go to
like Disneyland looking for their names
and the license plates and there are no
names in the license plates for any of
them you like like like my kid Harley
that's about to change though holy [__]
um it is that hook alone I was like oh
yeah they're not the and it's so weird
it was like I remember it was feeling
like when I saw the Billboards for the
dark night and there's a shot of Batman
on the Pod and I'm like you get my
motorcycle now the [__] this is stupid
then you see the movie and as soon as
it's like self-destruct goodbye and the
Batmobile blows up to become the bat pod
I was like that's [__] brilliant how
couldn't I have not seen that and then
I'd look at the billboard and be like
it's right there the Big Fat Tire how
did I not [__] see it same thing here
how did I not [__] see that they're
they're not the heroes they're the
[__] like you're the drags [__]
we're going to try make it work with the
DRS like that's a TV show yeah like it's
all about Redemption show's about if
they were all good at their jobs and
they were the best it'd be the [__]
Super Friends or the Justice League but
it's this it's about like you got
another shot to make your life count for
something so you oh I [__] right that's
how you [__] grabbed me dude I was
like oh I wasn't crying as hard as when
Barry's mom cried that but I had a whole
season for that but I bowled pretty hard
considering it was a [__] pilot I was
like that's a really beautiful [__]
kickoff notion yeah um I I wrote some
[__] down what else you got I'll write
some notes down here we go go to a two
shot these are the things I [__]
loved about Legend Of Tomorrow [__] I
wrote down as it went along the return
of Gideon dude Gideon is the onboard
[__] computer on the Wave Rider and
one of my favorite moments of [__]
flash season one was when they were in
the in the room with gidy and the was
Flash and Caitlyn and Cisco and they're
getting information they don't like
they've never encountered it before and
and [__] Harrison Wells is coming
back and it's a Race Against Time yes oh
it's so [__] real tense scene and
[__] and then like we gotta go we got to
go bar and they're like we got a [__]
polar circuit so she can't [__] tell
Wells and and he's like you know is
there any way Gideon is there any way
that you could just not tell Harrison
Wells we were here and she's like I will
you know I am programmed to do whatever
you say Barry Allen I'm I'm I'm about to
[__] cry I love this so [__] much
you have no idea and he's like why and
the computer says because you built me
and the [__] look on Grant Gus's face
man where he's just like it it's [__]
beautiful his mind-bending little moment
and I sat there [__] crying I was
like oh God this is so perfect kill me
now Jesus cuz life will never get better
in this moment don't touch it don't
touch it totally it was that it was like
don't don't don't just back away
oh so that being said with G I did get
emotional again with Gideon being on the
on board ship I was like it's all
happening this is what you [__] I
[__] I love Andrew chbg I know he did
that I know he was like sitting in a
writer room was going like oh let's use
Gideon as the voice someone will like
that and [__] I am that somebody I
went crazy for it um Ray uh Ray Palmer
says to Martin Stein do you remember my
paper and Martin Stein goes I don't
remember you Mr Palmer I know really
nice be keeps calling him Mr Palmer
would even call him Dr Dr Palmer but I'm
I'm a doctor
I did the [__] work I'm a doctor but
that also lends to there's Martin Stein
himself the [__] as Mark said right
before the show you were like they show
the posters of all the young Heroes and
then it's like there's your dad the guy
who buys the legends of Tomorrow
beer and the rest but you need him
that's the great what's his [__] name
oh Victor Garber oh I [__] love
Victor Garber um saw him on Titanic the
other day titanic was on table right he
the guy who built the Titanic this is
the guy who played Anthony sailor in the
original production of Sweeney Todd wow
yes and he plays God in God spell or
Jesus whatever you call that clown
character in the movie not in religion I
understand the clown character religion
is called Jesus but I'm talking about in
the movie God spell and God in real life
is is Morgan Freeman so yes it's not
Victor Garber no clearly yeah we all
know that come on well to some of us God
is Alanis moris it was a little pocket
in the 90s I won't take it away from
Morgan fre she had a minute we all had a
minute Mark um I love that though I
think that's a cool notion that he feels
like it feeds into the whole like this
is why ray goes on the trip cuz he's
like [__] Doctor Who taught me
doesn't even remember my work like he
feels very unimportant very small that's
good writing kids that's Mark Bernard
level good writing right there you know
what I'm saying I'm telling you that's a
bunch of people sitting around in
writer's room going like you know what
are his character traits they have to
either that or just happen luckily but
because it's all like you know how do
all of these characters at some point
match up with each other and they spent
a lot of plates on this show I [__]
salute anybody that's like we got many
stories to tell when I did Dogma that's
a lot of stories to juggle and [__] when
you have that many characters and
whatnot it's great when he two-hander
three-hander but this this is eight nine
people they got to write for every
[__] episode that great job at least
in these two that that we've seen so
far
okay um I died once you know what
happened nothing I said that white
Canary Stephanie from Madmen I said
that um
Brandon is Ray Palmer I says perfect
Char casting of character can I get some
water mat I'm [__] choking dude um
Kendra I give you water from my cup
thank you Kendra as uh okay this is
[__] deep cut spoilers so again watch
the show for reals I think the first
moment that really made me cry hard was
Kendra finds out uh
she's this old man's yeah spoilers Mom
Mother [__] crazy they're hunting for
like this professor at some college
who's been tracking Vandal Savage for
his entire life and so he's got
apparently the information like where
can we find him what does he do where
does he live where what are his patterns
and they're like well we got to go talk
to this guy who's been obsessed with
Vandal Savage for years and they go to
talk to him and he's your [__] kid
it's [__] he goes and you know he's
he's drawn to her and then finally you
know they set it up for a few minutes
and then he has a moment to say was it
you're as beautiful as I remember and
you're like what is it and did you meet
me before and there's a photo of like a
man a woman and a kid and you're like oh
my God is he the man thank you oh you're
amazing um Matt everybody Matt's head
that's a producer brings you water when
you need it um so the so you know you're
like oh maybe it's the guy he's
reincarnated version guy but he's the
baby in her arms yeah what a [__]
cool I've never seen that before in
something you know what I'm saying like
the notion of like here's a kid you
didn't know you had who's a [__]
grown adult older than you and you're
going to spend this little truncated of
time with him and then you know like he
spent his entire life obsessing over
this hoping that at some point he would
meet his parents again and knowing that
they would reincarnate because he's done
all the [__] homework so he knows
good piece of writing so great really
emotional um I dug that a lot
um who was someone one of them said mom
used to listen to Captain and tanil a
lot I think it was either Heatwave or
[__] Captain Cold good [__] line
they because they played I think Love
Will Keep Us Together yeah they went to
the Disco the bar scene in 1970 whatever
uh Kronos I said Kronos and the hawk
fight was badass all the hawk fight
stuff all Hawkman hawkwoman Taking
Flight Wings busting fighting [__]
[__] badass really [__] and again
like that to me is the unsung hero of
all this [__] cuz you're like can't
believe we live in a world where they're
showing [__] Hawks where the Hawks
are fighting and and that's the same
[__] storyline that I remember from
the comics where she's like I don't
[__] remember any of this he's like k
you must remember we reincarnated Souls
there have been so many different
versions of these [__] Hawk man and
hawk woman characters um when I was a
kid the hawk I got was on Buck Rogers
who really just literally had a [__]
Hawk hat what's his name Hawk FW Hawk
ship and he was like their Spock he was
emotionless like a bird for some reason
yeah cuz he's a bird
person none of them are those yeah
that's not from that show um all right
so what else we got man uh the excit the
professor kid Kendra's Dad when and he
was just like is that a laser gun that
was so cute I thought that was really
really cool um they're having fun with
the time stuff too we just they are
having a blast we go out for five
minutes you pick a fight with Boba Fett
the guy who plays Captain Cold is
amazing what's his name uh Dominic no
miller Dominic Marcel's his brother Heat
Wave he's [__] the way he plays
Captain Cole dude is [__] it's great
like he found a thing to do you know
what I'm saying like I appreciate when
an actor's like all right I got a thing
for it and he delivers everything in
this very particular way like just above
it all very spish not he don't cop James
sper but he reminds me of like Spader's
presence in it's like laconic intent
like it's very much like he's leaning
back into it but it's very precise it
pains me so much to do this you know
like everything hurts so badly um let me
see what else did I write down uh Kronos
versus the Legends that's there's a big
moment where Kronos [__] fights all
the legends Tomorrow there's a laser
fight and the Wave Rider takes off a as
good as you would see in any [__]
feature film yeah and like fun like they
hit him with a car yes like that's great
good [__] [__] spoilers all of this
is spoilers um let me see I said I
respect for all the moving parts so many
characters we talked about that uh
Kendra and Sarah punch and rip Hunter I
thought that was kind of fun uh the
Legends reveal I said there's The
Suicide Squad that's really what they're
doing here like it's the Justice League
plus The Suicide Squad they're having
their cake and in like there these
[__] over at CW and brante land they
cracked the code dude they're having the
time of their lives making dream it's
great oh my God it's so [__] smart um
let's see a collection of nobody's who
time doesn't really give a damn about
that's what somebody says and that
[__] broke my heart uh the the
spoilers again the death of rip Hunter's
family which is paid off as the opening
scene you see the future with Vandal
Savage and he kills some [__] random
woman and some kid Ain't So Random nope
just like good writing in TV turns out
to be something I never would have
thought of
that oh my God nothing's wasted you're
absolutely right so um that that is
really well done the professor's
necklace I don't know what that is I
forget what that is a reference to I
called it a total soap opera or soups
Opera coining that phrase soups Opera
soups Opera along with toilers in the
me and Mark creating language Fatman and
Batman word
Bank these are the key words by which
you could search our show soups up um
Martin Stein when he decides to go his I
thought his reason was and as a
middle-aged man had [__] struck home
with me I'm sure no kid watching the
show is going to be like Yay Martin
Stein but I was nice Blazer his [__]
his rationale was at my age you don't
know how many Adventures you have left
yeah it's really [__] quite sweet
like and again like yeah he's the one of
these things is not like the other in
the cast Vincent Garber because he's
classic [__] Broadway actor but man
this show benefits from having him every
way shape or form when you see somebody
that good at their job playing something
this goofy that seriously you take your
[__] ad off man I Mak dreams come
true some kids are going to see this for
the first time this is their first Adam
or [__] rip Hunter like most kids are
like rip Hunter who what now rip Hunter
is a viable [__] character for a
bunch of kids cuz like oh he's the time
traveling man yeah I mean it's really
smart it it does definitely take a page
from like the Battle Star Galactica
thing which this is a silly idea that if
we get the best [__] actors we can
find will absolutely Help Us sell it you
know you give me you know Mary McDonald
and you give me Edward James almost and
robot toasters who look just like
regular people is fine you know I'll do
I'll give you everything else I'll give
you planets named after you know
astrological signs I will give you all
of this [__] if those guys sell it and
Victor Garber is one of those guys like
he's selling it he gets a lot of screen
time in part two he gets like a really
funny bit where he meets spoilers they
go back in time to the 70s so he meets
his college age self and there's a
chance that he doesn't meet his wife
like once they go back in time there's
pictured right there man uh 1970s they
spent a little coin you you got to got
to put those outfits together and stuff
and rebuild the 70s to and granted it's
you keep it focused to your frame but
much they get a big walking shot I
thought I was impressed by that kind of
[__] but he he gets like he gets to act
his ass off in this and that's really
funny there's a lot of weed smoking I
you know I appreciate that a great deal
I love when things I love come together
I'm happy to do a flash but what I
really want to do is the pot smoking
episode of Legends of tomorrow yeah next
time you're doing that give me a ring a
ding um and Chong for you it's crazy
they do like a bunch of pot jokes
because they're in the 70s at one point
uh [__] Martin Young Martin St Stein
is like let's spark a duie and talk
about
physics [__] good [__] man um Canary
takes joints from the 70s when they
leave onto the Wave Rider so setups for
later dude yep do a whole episode where
they just get bed on the Wave Rider
that's my episode please Andrew let me
do the one where they're all in one room
getting a high yeah that's that's the
bottle episode The Breakfast Club
episode essentially um what else Martin
remets his wife very [__] sweet when
they do that piece because at one point
Martin [__] up his chances of meeting
his wife and then of course things get
writed
but there is there's there is a there is
something not quite irrevocable because
yes it because we deal in time here but
we're dealing in time and we're dealing
with people for whom time is never
permanent yeah but yeah there's some
there's some some casualties yeah and I
was okay with that
one you I like it I can't we don't want
to spoil it but oh my god well we spoil
everything yeah really that you're I I
just didn't like that I we talked about
it I didn't like that actor so much so
he ain't gone I know there's no way it's
a nice respit though could you
imagine my God I can't stand I like the
dude I can't believe though pilot
episode they're like yeah alman's gone
sorry whoop and you know whether he's he
ain't going to stay gone they're like
you kidding we put a lot of money in
that poster surely he'll be back but
even if they take him out for a few
episodes It's kind of [__] badass
it's Prett way to start your show where
you're like one of the stars is gone in
uh in Buffy the Vampire Slayer yeah of
all things the movie or TV show the TV
show in the very I only acknowledge the
movie I that guy Captain contrarian Fran
kazui Fran kazui uh but in the very in
the pilot episode of of Buffy the
Vampire Slayer there's a character in
the opening credits who gets killed in
the first show and the trick is like
look he's part of the show clearly he's
in the opening credits he's going to be
in here for like six years and they kill
him in the first epis right away it's
just the nothing is safe here and did
they then take him out of the front CR
yeah put him in there once the dude was
just like thanks hey I told my mom I was
on the show forever I'm in the opening
credits we did a shoot I said I was even
in the credits and they never get rid of
people in the credits no [__] the Buffy
[__] they didn't kill Phoebe nobody
likes Phoebe who's Phoebe I'm friends oh
people didn't like Phoebe I don't
know Mark's making [__] up these kids
have never seen friends I didn't I
watched one or two episodes and I was
like this is this ain't for me no this
apartment is way too big I lived in New
York don't look like this nuh and we the
roaches yeah and you don't have any
black friends I want in New York that's
what I said too the same thing I said
where the black
friends on BET on a show called Black
friends s Martin and Tisha Campbell um
oh my God that's right it kind of was um
boy oh boy they [__] cracked it man
this is this is a fun [__] show I
don't want to spoil the rest of it we've
spoiled so [__] much yeah but um this
it's like it's like watching a [__]
Blockbuster movie every week they keep
this up and they can't not you know what
I'm saying like launch strong Grant
granted it's a pilot and they tend to
spend a little more money on a pilot but
the bar is high man they're going back
and forth through time as we heard in an
earlier episode Jonah Hex they gra DC
universe characters they can do [__]
what's his name not uh Sergeant Rock
they could do
[__] want it be boring I want to see
the Kandy episode
you see those silent B eyes that I'm
wearing Kandy last boy on Earth that's
right man so that means they go to the
Future yeah because why couldn't you
it's true you can gowhere the future
deep to the Future that's I like this
show a lot like I I did when they first
announced it when I saw the trailer I
was like oh I guess that's cute they're
doing like a team show good for them and
stuff but I hadn't watched flash even at
that point so when they first talked
about it I was like wow it's nice to see
things are working for them congrat you
guys things are working for me man like
that show is good that's one more
program I get to watch you know what I'm
saying like I'm not like Jason Muse who
watches every single [__] thing on
television every [__] day he
downloads four new shows and watches
them all like he watches everything he's
like impressive dude with the pen and
the Matrix with all the TVs and [__] who
says things that are very confusing m is
just like that guy I think about so
itation of the
anomaly Ain that guy think he's ever
heard the word anomaly but um it it's
forget where I was going with that
analogy I don't know it's good time I
just got excited by the idea that they
could maybe meet Sergeant
Rock I said that before yeah and I was
like that's boring who gives a [__]
about Sergeant rock well I'm just I'm
thinking from a purely because from a DC
fan from a DC fan perspective and from a
we can pull this off on a weekly basis
totally like you go to the old west
that's fine World War II we can probably
fake that dude [__] Sergeant Rock
haunted tank [__] you know what I'm
saying haunted [__] tank creature
Commandos that's not bad it's a deep DC
bench they could pull from that [__]
Zack Snider is never going to touch
cinematically so keep going kids yes
like doing the Lord's work over there at
bran land and at CW I never thought I'd
say that I never in my life thought I
would say this but God damn it I love
the
CW a Network full of shirtless teen boys
and I love it all love mytic face neck
and [__] um you know what I also dig on
a [__] Legends tomorrow there a very
tiny thing but do you see R's suit
constantly is moving yes the PO when
he's wearing the atom suit it's
constantly [__] moving and it's a I
don't that's not a special effect a CG
effect I think they built that into the
suit yeah just like just constantly
woring really nice touch man like his
Tech is alive it was kind of dope man
but he's my I think he's my Allstar for
the show I think Brandon is my emotional
Journey like he's wonderful in the show
whole cast is [__] great don't get me
wrong but I think he's the one that I'm
like a like I love his story the most
like he's the there he is man he just
wants to be a hero so badly he wants to
make a difference he's so smart he can
get so small so tiny so tiny to fight
Injustice um but it's a really sweet
story man that they you like cuz
honestly you can go like you couldn't do
that Batman let's say they had Batman
and Batman's like I'm a loser of the
future like that would never happen but
you could do that with Ray Palmer yeah
and you know what is the most people
know outside of comments about the atom
anyway nothing so it's like looks a lot
like Iron Man is he Rich yeah kind of a
lot like Iron Man what did you do get
small like anman yeah yeah and and to be
fair Iron Man's a lot like Batman yeah
they're all a lot like they're all very
much from the same well and we love that
well we drink from it all the time it's
the Fountain of Youth [__] keep
you young thinking about this [__]
elixir of life you ain't kidding you
spend you spend all your [__]
remaining days watching Legends of
tomorrow before you know the grave will
be here for
you and there there it is you'll spent
your time wisely you will be a legend of
today in your own of tomorrow it's good
[__] show man I don't need to sell it
to you I'm telling you you've seen some
of the footage already you've seen the
spots on TV do it join in man this
another [__] God damn it [__]
berlan right now it's like Pixar year
first 10 years yes you know what I'm
saying like can't can't lose he's
Gretzky from 84 to 88 he's Pixar before
cars
to he's grety before Los
Angeles he's a glow Trotters
all the [__] time yeah he's metalark
lemon we didn't Fu finish giving him his
dues metalark lemon one of the most
famous [__] people on the planet he
just died fairly recently and stuff and
he had a quiet rest of his life where he
was a religious person and stuff into I
think he was into the Lord but this was
a man who traveled everywhere dude was
probably one of the biggest [__]
stars on the planet yet if I turned to
my kid and I was like who's metal Arch
lemon she'd cry your dad's high and say
weird funny things is that a flavor of
ice cream isn't that sad though like man
was a [__] Giant
and to us when he passed I'm sure you
noticed I noticed I [__] stopped for
a minute to be like this [__] dude
man like he was [__] everything when
I was a kid he's funny as [__] he's
[__] talented and [__] and then like
he passed from a world that had moved on
to [__] Kanye West and the
Kardashians and other things like that I
remember I did take my kid to see the
globe TRS did you really yeah where this
was in Jersey they were playing at ruter
and he had loved it I because you can't
be like eight and not get a biggest
[__] kick out of this you can't be
[__] 18 or 80 and not get a big kick
out like even the what is they call the
magic circle the warm-up Circle it's
[__] good [__] man and again these
cats are practically superheroes they
had their own cartoon yeah they had
comic books I'm sure they [__] were
on television they had a movies like
they were [__] big man and that's
like to tie it back in to the ray Palmer
kind of like you know I died and nobody
really [__] noticed and [__] like
that that I don't know that seems to be
a thing for me I want to I want to die
where you know everybody [__] knows I
don't understand these people who don't
tell you they're not sick until they die
like I'm one of those cats where I'm
like got a hangnail stop everyone
[__] stop and help me listen you
should always have your fingers on the
91 you ain't in case I'm so not Noble at
all I know I'm okay that's why I like
reading about Noble characters they give
me a little spine I give me something to
look to like o i be like Ray Palmer I
never in my [__] life Mark ever
thought I would be like I love the Adam
you know nobody ever but they did it
that's the gifted folks over there
[__] working on thecw shows they made
[__] the Adam viable dude yeah not
just viable the lead of a TV show yeah
and somebody I want to see more somebody
I'm like get rid of the other ones just
watch his [__] show feel bad for this
guy yeah I am the ray Palmer of
filmmakers very small while being very
very big it's very bizarre and when I
die nobody will remember not unless
[__] rip Hunter comes back [__]
gets us to jump in Our Fate is what we
make is that what they said Our Fate is
what we make for ourselves that's from
Terminator 2 good movie Very that's my
quote good movie nice job clearly we've
run out of [__] to say for just like I
like that you know what I'll allow it
but you know
what she returns but you watch your step
McCoy the um it's it's called The
Legends of Tomorrow folks watch it DC
Legend of tomorrow it's true yeah DC's
Legend of tomorrow man can't believe
they [__] did it as good as they did
yet they did it and here we are [__]
watching it there they are look at them
all look at them Heroes all of them look
at poor Martin Stein always stuck in the
back hi it's me always stumbling around
like a confused grandfather I can vote
why are we on this roof
I can
vote I've got a dad bod tell you
something I wish I had Victor garbage B
not bad for you know what I'm saying for
a dude who's [__] he's got to be 60s
yeah this looks pretty [__] good not
bad Sans Bel happening he's killing it
you know he don't need the other guy's
body to become Firestorm they got to do
an episode where he's in the [__] oh
that'd be great you know what I'm saying
like a reverse kind of thing I'm all for
it um leave us out of the mix clearly
we're not doing the good work that they
are like o let's do a mixup episode yeah
he looks [__] badass dude let's give
Firestorm some love can't believe this
[__] character is on television it's
crazy it's beautiful it's a beautiful
thing and they're doing it right man his
costume looks like his costume got the
big old flame head and stuff it's not
like in the comics where it's just fire
coming out his head but like that's what
be weird yeah that' be really weird
looked like a skater like a figure
skater there they are man ah ebony ivory
that's Fatman on Batman right there yep
there it is folks Legends of Tomorrow is
uh happening I believe tomorrow yes and
or if you've seen it's already on go
watch it and [__] and then watch this
and and compare notes see if you like
the same [__] you love it as much as we
love it let us know write to we don't
have an address write to us on Twitter
[__] we got twitters totally you got a
Twitter you got one of them twitters you
on the twitters I'm on the twitters tell
them your twitters uh Mark Bernard with
a c with a c not with a k yes I at that
Kevin Smith with a c not with a k no
with a that' be weird that' be very
strange um what a great time to be live
kids what a great time go watch this
show tomorrow man of course Flash and
Arrow return this week thank God man
more [__] king shark coming from what
I understand yes and I [__] I hear
there's a young buck director on the
rise might be doing an episode I'm so
excited just like Tim Miller I got the
world B of balls
now run Kevin run yeah right oh don't
you're make me cry I almost [__] bald
again talking about the goddamn computer
dude I can't tell you how [__]
touching it was when she when the
computer was like you created me Bar
Allen I was
like I gasped Inward and well I guess
you don't gasp outward I gasp I almost
collapsed a lung I gasped so hard oxygen
overload I love this [__] all right man
that's all the time we got for this week
man for Fatman on Batman I'm Kevin Smith
Mark Bernard don't forget man some come
see us here on Friday on Monday Tuesday
Monday Wednesday and Friday we're coming
all the time always all over your face
neck and [__] sometimes your back
little bit squeegee turn around we say
and then a little on the back same fact
we just lost all the audience like e why
does the show have to end so [__] it
got weird it did sorry about that sorry
Mom same fat Time same fat channel what
channel is that Mark
www.youtube.com Kevin
Smith
[Music]
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder